the crucible axe armor set one of the
coolest armor sets i have seen in eldon
ring in my 40 hours of game time so far
you can find it all the way up by the
capital city in a place called rhiza
heroes grave it's kind of a dungeon area
you're gonna have to deal with these you
know giant rolling horse back things
like chariot things that'll kill you in
one shot luckily enough it's really not
that hard to run past like even right
off the rip you can run down to the
kind of medium safety slot here and as
it goes up i could have run down but i
you know i just didn't want to risk it i
think i wanted to look at something
really quick but the rest of the time
you can pretty much just run straight to
the boss room so that you can get the
armor set so as soon as he goes up the
hill you can run all the way down if you
go right in between these two pillars
you're gonna be completely safe because
you're gonna have another chariot coming
straight down but you'll be safe right
here and as it's going up you can just
run straight up it's gonna be a close
one but you can make it to this left
safety slot here and immediately run to
the next area now here you're gonna have
to deal with two chariots kind of like a
puzzle going up and down at the same
time actually almost got hit there and
didn't even pay attention but there's a
safety slot in them in between them
right here so the one that was rolling
at you up top is gonna come down and you
can just really easily avoid it by just
going left side here and then go back to
the right when the one on the right goes
back up really not hard very very basic
uh the one on the left is probably
coming down i was kind of worried about
the one coming up right there but you're
just gonna be totally fine in between
these two pillars right here with the
last chariot that you have to deal with
you can just run over to the safety slot
over here on the left and you can just
run right past it when it goes by you so
this
is the boss room there are some
skeletons in this area luckily enough
there's a state of murakai maraca i just
say morocco because i like saying the
word and the boss room is at the bottom
of these stairs now this boss fight is
one of the hardest boss fights i've
dealt with in this game it reminds me of
ornstein and smoke because you have to
deal with two crucible knights at the
same time that have different move sets
i'm going to be showing you guys a lot
of the boss fight here because it took
me many many tries to finally beat these
two bosses with the deer antler coat
rack guy here you'll notice that i'm
just kind of standing in front of them
i'm not really running in circles
that is where i found the most success
isn't running in circles when you run in
circles they just aggro you both of them
do at the same time but when you stand
in front of them
one kind of goes off on its own and one
attacks and it's pretty easy dodges you
know i'm still getting hit because i
don't know the the move set perfectly at
this point but the move sets that they
give you when you just stand in front of
them are just much easier to dodge than
when you're just running in a circle
because they have some seriously long
reaches with the weapons that they have
so you just kind of stand in front of
them and once you get one of the bosses
down to half health they're gonna go
into phase two both of these bosses have
phase twos that's why i try and focus
on one so the one i got to half health
has a hook attack and an aerial attack
that will just kind of dodge right at
you the hook isn't too bad although if
you really don't time it right you can
be caught and it is an insta kill if you
get caught in that hook grab so
at least they're mostly easily dodgeable
and then the rest of the attacks are
exactly the same along with this aoe
laser attack that is extremely easy to
dodge so right here i get one of the
guys down and then the fight is much
easier obviously when there's only one
of them to deal with basically this is
just a normal crucible night fight that
we found up in limb grave it's pretty
much the exact same fight although there
is one extra move this guy has where
he'll spin his sword in a really cool
way and slam it into the ground
extremely easy to avoid this guy's got a
wide reach with a shield bash mechanic a
ground punch earthquake style type deal
that you kind of have to dodge late on
that always helped me just knowing okay
dodge late when i see him lift up his
foot and that helped a lot so here's the
aoe attack again really easy to dodge
there's actually like two effects there
that if you linger around or try to
dodge into early after he does it it uh
it is still extremely difficult to avoid
and you can still get hit by it phase
two he's got his tail just like in the
normal fight up in limgrave and he has
his aerial attack really not too
difficult to deal with especially when
there's just one on its own once you
learn the move set not too bad at all
guys i really appreciate you watching
this video i really hope it helped i
hope you enjoy the armor set that you'll
get when you beat this boss i'm going to
show you my reaction to it and
everything i stream this game every
single day for 10 hours a day right now
on my twitch channel twitch.dv says htc
jig i would love to have you guys there
and just talk all things elden ring have
a great day guys enjoy the armor set
greed
yes
yes
i gotta i gotta lean back for a second
bro we got the sword we got the helmet
we got the armor we got the gauntlets we
got the greaves first try right guys
yo motive let's go
thank you for the 10 gifted subs
let's go
oh we gotta take a look at this armor
set huh absolutely we do this looks real
nice
that's clean af bro